i think there's a very real possibility
that we don't even see an opportunity
for trump to be re-elected following
this news
from timcast.com oath keepers leader and
10 members charged with seditious
conspiracy over january 6 and there it
is
we we heard from marjory taylor green
that there was going to be an attempt to
disqualify members of congress and maybe
even the president himself
there's now an organization out of north
carolina filing a lawsuit saying that
madison cawthorne is no longer
he's disqualified from running for
reelection because he incited
insurrection against the united states
wow
now they have their sedition charges
finally and a lot of people were saying
all throughout last year and we've even
said this there's no insurrection
charges trespassing come on
well you know what i think now
i think they sat on these charges
because they wanted to make sure
sedition was fresh in the mines the
american public
in an election year
and so here we go yep they're going to
ramp up they're going to start claiming
c it was sedition therefore anyone who
participated in the rally anyone who
helped to organize or in any way was
associated with it you have committed in
incited insurrection and you can't hold
office they're going to go after trump
they're going to go after marjorie
taylor green and they are they're
already going after medicine cathedral
and you just throw in more people
anybody who's who's opposing the
establishment well the timing here is
very odd it took him one year one year
to to press charges i mean what was
going on here this is extremely unusual
to the point where a lot of people were
saying well the oath keepers they must
be fed stewart rhodes is definitely a
fed well now he's getting some serious
you know federal charges which it
doesn't look like he's he's a fed here
but but again one year
does it i i see it's just mind-boggling
kenzinger was like ray epps was only
telling people to go into the the
capital he didn't do it himself so
that's fine but trump held a rally where
he said be strong and that's incitement
you know this guy is a crackpot but you
can you can see that it's it's agenda
driven and the ray epps thing that's his
name right yeah
really screwed him over it really threw
him for a loop and they're freak they
can't figure out how to deal with that
guy for those unfamiliar this is the guy
he's seen in a bunch of videos saying
he's telling everyone to go into the
capitol and people are wondering why he
wasn't criminally charged and now it's
at the forefront and they have no answer
there was people calling him feds the
day before the event because he was
calling for violence and destruction of
government property before the event
during the event he's on camera calling
for property destruction and storming
the capital people are chanting fed fed
yeah
and thomas massey uh basically streamed
this video from his phone when he was
talking to the who is he talking to the
head of the the attorney general
um and and then ted cruz picked it up um
i i think i find glenn greenwald's
analysis of this pretty compelling that
it would be quite typical for
the government to do this kind of thing
but i think in terms of the politics of
it i think it's pretty weak sauce going
into the election
going back to my earlier point
if you're looking at empty grocery
shelves and you can't afford to feed
your family and maybe you've been forced
out of your job because of a vaccine
mandate
all the drama about january 6. and i i
was
super critical
of anyone that participated in january 6
and i wouldn't apologize for anybody
that
was either committing violence or or
being near it you just don't do that
right
um lock them up yeah but that's charged
yeah but that said
this is not the democratic solution to
surviving the re-election
but they think it is they think it is
what what else do they got and i get it
they're gonna double down and this this
this looks fundamentally political and
and they're gonna play their cards and
see what happens if they succeed or i
got to be honest if they even try these
lawsuits to disqualify members of
congress and they already are so i don't
even know what i'm saying at this point
but i just think you're asking for
serious trouble in this country
because what happens when you get a
judge who says we agree matt you you get
some you get some lefty establishment
judge and they say we hear your case we
agree madison cawthorn you can't run for
re-election what do you think the
right's gonna do you think they're gonna
be like oh well gee i guess we can't
have our representative anymore or do
you think they're gonna be like screw
you no and then what happens when you
start getting congressional districts
where there's no agreement on what the
proper ballots are because certain names
have been removed from only some of them
what happens when you get one precinct
saying you can't disqualify him that's
wrong we support him what happens when
republican areas in the district all
defend him and democratic areas refuse
and what
what happens when they actually re-elect
him and then the democrats are just like
look at this court ruling he can't he
cited insurrection under the 14th
amendment section 3 and they do it
anyway do you think people just sit back
and say ah lost this one i guess we'll
carry on no
no no i don't they're gonna scream the
courts have ruled he can't run
they're cheating they're breaking the
law and the right's going to say your
ridiculous lawsuit is meritless and the
judge is wrong and there's going to be
no agreement on what the law actually is
supposed to be at that point yeah i
think that's a credible theory to
definitely kind of look at and examine
here especially with the justice
department announcing a new task force
for domestic terrorism the dhs also made
some very alarming statements yesterday
about domestic bomb production so you
know
it might not be enough politically but
that doesn't mean that there's something
uh later down the line that still might
happen that they have planned uh to work
in a bigger political favor so you know
there's some people talking about the
possibility of false flag domestic you
know attacks here in the united states
to blame the right and and the way
things are moving they're really moving
in a very negative way where we are only
becoming more divided uh people are
having more hatred for their fellow
american and the ingredients that are
causing that the corporate media the
social the social media i don't see
those ingredients going away i see them
only being added more into this larger
stirring pot of these globalist elites
that want us all fighting and attacking
each other but you don't have to eat out
of that stewpot that's the key is to get
away from that propaganda and away from
the hatred and away from the fear and
away from a lot of the bull crap but but
if if there's going to be
larger staged events that create you
know victims and casualties
it's going to be very hard for a lot of
people to ignore those kind of larger
how do you help people keep an open
eyeball for that kind of stuff
it's very difficult um
it's it's not easy i mean there's a lot
of things working behind the scenes that
we we aren't even privy to we don't even
know about um
and that's that's asking how do you put
a genie back in uh a genie bottle you
gotta get you gotta do something that
i've tried to do i've been super
involved in politics for most of my
career i was a tea party organizer and
and i did a rand paul super pac i did a
gary johnson super pac
and and what we've tried to do
is leave all of that aside
and you know the original aspiration for
for us that free the people was to be
sort of trans partisan try to find
common american values that could bring
people together on various subjects and
see if we couldn't just get along on
something
and and i think the first step of that
is like if you if you go into this
saying you know what i'm team red
i'm red pilled
those other guys are monsters
it doesn't really work that way
so i've i've tried to spend some time
talking to my progressive opponents on
some of these issues
i gotta say that lockdowns have kind of
blown that up
because now we all really hate each
other and it's very difficult to find
that common ground but but again the
future the anti-authoritarian future
we're going to find people across the
political spectrum
that are fed up with all this crap
and want to do something different we
talk about the left and the right and
then when i look at the political
compass there's actually an up and a
down where the authoritarians you can
have a leftist authoritarian or rightist
authoritarian but then when you go down
you get to the individualism and so you
do see leftist individualists and
rightist individualists i think one of
them i think the left
uh overwhelmingly is authoritarian there
are very few people among democrats who
are anti-authorities i'm wondering if
the line on this quad graph isn't
straight lines but actually as it goes
to the left it naturally tends up
towards authoritarianism and as it goes
towards the right it tends down towards
there is visualism there is a such thing
as left libertarianism but it's
substantially uh
less populated because it's a very weird
political space
when it comes to the modern version of
the left uh what we have in the united
states today with the democratic party
and leftist activists is because they're
overwhelmingly collectivist
even the the the democratic activists or
progressives or dsa types who don't like
biden would support him due to tribalism
and collectivism then you have the
run-of-the-mill lay democratic voter who
doesn't know anything but adheres to the
authority out of ignorance and fear so
it's not that they're authoritarian
these people in the sense that they're
you know like we want you to bend the
knee and do as you're told it's that
they don't know anything don't want to
know anything and say i'm going to do
what i'm told by brian stelter
authoritarian follower as opposed to an
authoritarian leader yeah yeah i mean i
figure there's an audience i mean there
there's people hard set in their ways
and and maybe it has something to do
with age where you just stop thinking
about the world anymore you you are who
you are and you've accepted that
but i think there's an opportunity
particularly with young people i'm
trying to be an optimist here so hang
out with me for just a second
i think a lot of young people are
searching for something else and i think
there is a small l
libertarian solution where we can sort
of accommodate our different cultural
differences and you can be conservative
you can be liberal you can be all these
different things
as long as we agree to solve problems on
the local level
and live our lives however we see fit as
long as you don't hurt people or take
their stuff and and that ultimately is
the libertarian solution i'm i'm i'm
selling t-shirts too tonight sorry it
says don't hurt people and don't take
their stuff yeah i agree with that
it's a simple message that i wish more
people would just understand and and
that's literally
a lot of people's philosophies that that
if they instituted would would create
such a better world yeah just don't
steal that's that's it but it's got to
be like i don't think that's a political
solution you're talking about changing
hearts and minds
and talking about a little bit of
humility when we deal with other people
who who may be confused about using the
power of state to force other people to
be vaccinated
for people whose minds are still open we
should talk to them
and and that's the opportunity here for
for people that are hardened
authoritarians
you can't they're well they're done
here's a question that transforms them
what on this show you know that you may
have seen or you guys has been
conservative
is saying defy the state and the
authority is that conservative no no
absolutely not uh
opposing vex mandates is that a
conservative position
no that's a tribal political position i
guess it's a liberty position it's
interesting to me that many of the
people we're trying to convince have
this view that this show is conservative
when we almost we rarely if ever talk
about like abortion and taxes and
traditional family values or anything
like that yet somehow
that's that's that's what we're accused
of being that's what they say when our
discussions are almost always
libertarian you could argue i think that
opposing vast mandates is conservative
because it's like this weird liberal
thing where they want to change the
whole way the system's built and we're
like yo natural immunity is a thing
there's other ways let's not rush this
that's not concern that's kind of like
the let's let's
conserve our energy let's slowly move
through this traditional conservatism is
uh and feel free to chime in after i say
this my interpretation is upholding
traditional values that help preserve a
system that has led to success
that would be protect the system defend
the status quo
and then progressivism or leftism is the
way it's we we've usually described it
is the left pulls towards progress and
the right holds them back a little bit
and they slowly move towards you know
new ways of doing things but not too
much too fast and what we've got now is
the chain is snapped the right is
stumbling back a little bit only a
little bit and the left has just taken
off running like you know the dog
getting loose on the leash
so i don't see anything that we're
talking about being conservative because
we're actually fairly reformist we're
complaining about the establishment
we're actually revolutionary when we
call for the end of the federal reserve
so how is any of that that's amazing the
federal reserve is is a revolutionary
calling for an end of the fed
is a revolutionary idea that's wild and
they would be like it's a conservative
show i'm like bro you guys are defending
massive multinational corporations how
we convince those people
i honestly
we can we can tell the truth we can be
honest but short of using their tactics
and manipulation i don't see how you you
change people's minds
that's a good one i don't know music
like i i don't i don't think we followed
the authoritarian's paradigm because
their their
whole role is to manipulate
and scare people into falling in line
and our model is is more like joe rogan
let's have a conversation i'm not here
to tell you what to think but i'm going
to insist that you start thinking for
yourself
and to me that's our paradigm and i know
it sounds a little hippy-dippy but
we're not gonna out authoritarian
authoritarians we gotta we gotta figure
out a totally different way to engage
people
and i think people that have gone
through this this two years of
of of lockdown torture and all the
psychological and personal damage we've
done particularly to children
i think people might be hungry for an
alternative and and we're that
revolution but i think our tactics are
different we respect people enough not
to tell them well so this is the funny
thing right the uh historical left and
right you guys are you're familiar where
it originates the french revolution
right where the people sitting on the
right were the the they were the
monarchists or the you know they wanted
to keep the systems aristocracy yeah and
then the left was the revolutionary
communist lefty types the funny thing is
we're sitting here saying the
establishment is busted and broken
they're bad we got to vote them all out
get rid of that we want to end the fed
we want dramatic revolutionary change in
this country and the quote unquote left
people like hassan or vosh are saying
the massive multinational corporations
are correct and we should be forced to
buy their products by the status quo
establishment politicians and i'm like
that makes them right-wing
it doesn't matter if your economic
position is nationalization of a
corporation you are his on the
historical scale based on the original
definition the right wing defending
aristocracy and we're here complaining
about it fascist absolute fascist thanks
for checking out this segment from the
tim cast irl podcast if you want to
watch live you can check out this
channel monday through friday at 8 pm
and don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel and if
you want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time